waukesha wisconsin you know there was
the attack oh we're not allowed to call
it an attack
there was the incident
at the christmas parade where a blm
supporter drove his suv down and killed
five people and injured many many more
people well now that number has been
updated it wasn't just five people it's
six people
a sixth person a child an eight-year-old
child
has died from the car attack in waukesha
wisconsin
now the number of people injured it's no
longer just 20 people or 40 people it's
now up to 61 people injured
cbs 8 is reporting that the
eight-year-old boy died and his
12-year-old brother was also hit during
the massacre
the
you're not going to hear a lot of this
from the establishment media but the guy
who drove the car was
according to a social media reportedly a
blm supporter a big critic of of uh
trump and the republicans and
conservatives he espoused black
nationalist rhetoric this came right
after the kyle rittenhouse verdict which
was exploited by the media and tried to
turn into a blm cause celeb and
and he was also this driver of the car
out on bail
he had been he had actually just been uh
leaving another domestic incident but he
had been arrested for domestic abuse he
hit he hit a woman the mother of his
children he hit her with a car same cory
used to hit kill all these other people
and he was released on bail and the bail
was a thousand bucks and before that
just last year he was arrest arrested
again for all these problems he was
released on 500 bail this guy is a
degenerate dirty rotten criminal who
should have been locked up at least at
least locked up
for a very long time if not the rest of
his life
and because of the compassionate
liberals and criminal justice reform
which
these days even many republicans are
embracing because of that
61 people were injured and six people
were killed including an eight-year-old
boy and who knows more people might die
there's still people in critical
condition
because of that compassion and now you
want to hear the cherry on top of the
sunday
he's got he's got the opportunity for
bail again
now the bail is very high this time
they've set the bail at five million
dollars
why are they giving him that opportunity
at all
he is a repeat
violent
career criminal who has killed who has
injured many many people and killed
multiple people why does he have the
opportunity for bail
i agree he should have a trial though it
though
in a in a simple efficient just world
that isn't fallen
this would be over already
but yes he of course he's entitled to a
trial
but he's not entitled to go out there's
if the guy goes he's already
skipped his bail before he's already
he's already committed crimes while out
on bail so just you can't give him that
opportunity again
and in our crazy
compassionate world
he is being given that opportunity we'll
get to more of that in just one second
first though
kamikoto makes great japanese steel
kitchen knives using over 800 years of
traditional techniques from japan is
this intimidating to you when i'm
holding up this kamikoto knife it's
intimidating to me they only use steel
source from mills in japan each blade is
crafted using techniques that have been
honed and perfected by generations of
knife smiths each knife comes in a
beautiful heavy duty ash wood box very
beautiful presentation here
it makes sure that the knife is stored
safely and also makes kamikodo a great
gift especially around christmas time
each kamikoto knife
goes through a rigorous 19-step process
that takes several years from start to
finish to complete
the expert blade smiths forge and shape
raw steel into hardy blades polishing
and sharpening them to an excruciatingly
fine edge look at that each knife is
individually inspected kamikoto is so
confident about their knives that each
knife comes with a lifetime guarantee i
really like them
they're really really cool they are a
great gift or
you're if you're like me you're probably
going to want to just keep them for
yourself kamikodo is currently having a
massive black friday sale and on top of
that sale you can get an additional 50
bucks off any purchase you make with
discount code knowles click the link
below or go to kamikodo.com
use promo code knowles save an extra
fifty dollars today
there was also a media narrative there's
so many lies in the media around this
this attack one of them was that the
reason he drove his suv into the crowd
into the christmas parade and killed a
bunch of grannies the dancing grannies
was one of the names of one of the
groups and killed children is because he
was being chased by the police that was
that was the narrative that was starting
to form
and it of course it is because nothing
can be this criminal's fault everything
has to be the fault of the police
why did you commit the crime the police
made me do it the law made me do it the
society made me do it it can never be
the fault of the criminal
and especially when you add the racial
dimension here that the left pushes it's
all the white guy has to always be at
fault even if the cop is black actually
as is the case in in
this part of wisconsin it's still it's
the white guy and the poor black guy is
always the victim
and the you see it in the narrative
around thanksgiving the settlers the
pilgrims they're always the bad guy the
indians are always the victim there's no
ambiguity here
it always breaks to and even if the
reality doesn't match that narrative the
the reality must be made to conform
hold up i'm glad you like that clip ring
the bell
ring the bell just subscribe it's very
simple now i know even if you ring the
bell you might not get the notifications
which is why it's very important to head
on over to apple podcasts or spotify or
stitcher or google play or wherever you
listen to podcasts type in the michael
knowles show
subscribe leave a five star review we'll
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you